[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
number of people gathered the king is
now approaching Randolph Cathedral and
the start of this service later on today
he will attend the Senate it was
Parliament
and then go to Cardiff Castle to
hold a reception for a number of people
who've been Gathering outside but for
now the first call here to this great
Cathedral just to the West
of Cardiff City
and will be received
Bible
by the king's law of attempt
Forsyth Glamorgan who met him a little
early and also advised Lord lieutenant
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
the Great West End of Randolph Cathedral
where inside
so many representing
the nation of Wales wait for this
service to begin
the king and queen console will then be
received
by a line of dignitaries
starting with the first minister
Secretary of State for Wales all the
same
Glamorgan Lord mayor of Cardiff she's
Constable for South Wales police
of course the dean of this Cathedral of
flandoff
the king now meeting
the dean who will present the Interfaith
leaders including
the moderator of the Free Church Council
the chair of the Muslim Council of Wales
the Chief Executive Officer of sighton
Interfaith Council for Wales
the Evangelical Alliance
the dean will now present the king to
the Archbishop of Wales and the bishop
of Landon
foreign
and the most Reverend Andrew John is the
Archbishop of Wales